[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a french comedy film
called jackie in women's kingdom
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is set in an imaginary
matriarchal totalitarian country called
the bubunia in bubunia the roles of men
and women are reversed up to the point
where the male population is deprived of
any civil rights including work
education military service freedom of
marriage etc men wear headscarves and
long veils to cover every part of their
body and they dress modestly while women
are allowed to wear pants and shirts the
country has been led by the family of
ruthless female general s for decades
moreover the significant positions in
politics business and the military are
all held by women while men are expected
to do all the domestic work and look
pretty for women's pleasure in the
opening scene we are introduced to a
handsome young man named jackie who is
whipped for the general s's daughter and
the future leader of the state the
colonists the television shows a live
ceremony from the grand muschery palace
the event is held by the general s to
announce something important to the
people and also to execute the male
criminals of the month before the
ceremony two royal white horses are
worshipped as per tradition they are
considered sacred in the country then
the honorable ministers of the nation
who are all women are introduced at last
the colonness and the general s appear
in front of the cheering crowd the
colonness is the most eligible bachelor
of the town and is liked by all while
her mother and the ruler generaless is
very strict and is feared by everyone
jackie does household work while
watching the show on tv
just then his mother returns from work
exhausted jackie tends to her needs and
the two watch the show while chatting
his mother claims that four girls from
the town asked for her permission to
marry him at her work it is clear that
jackie is popular among the girls of the
town because of his beauty they hit on
the guy every day to the point that he
feels violated although he can get any
girl he likes jackie only has the call
in s in his heart and wishes to marry
her someday in the show the criminals
are hanged in front of a cheering crowd
in bubunia the only source of nutrition
is a white sticky substance that is
delivered from water pipe-like sinks
called paste the general s then gives a
speech stating the importance of the
paste she also declares that she wants
to resign from her post and hand the
responsibility over to the colonness but
as per tradition the coloness needs to
be married before taking over the throne
she announces that all the men from the
country should compete against each
other for a chance to marry the
colonness and become the big dummy she
ends the speech by inviting every man to
the grand bubunary ball for the
competition
jackie is overly delighted by the
announcement he runs outside in
happiness jumping and dancing like every
other man in the country on the way he
sees a group of men praying to a random
horse to make them into the big dummy he
joins them and prays as well
one of the men is jackie's cousin virgil
who claims that the horse talked to him
and said that he will become the big
dummy jackie calls him out stating that
lying is a big blasphemy as they talk
some teenage girls nearby call jackie
hot and argue about who is going to
marry him following that jackie virgio
and his brother go to a clothing shop to
buy veils for the grand baboonery ball
virgil's parents are rich in contrast to
jackie's mother they make fun of him for
not being able to afford a nice veil the
salesgirl hits on jackie saying that he
is the most handsome of them all and
that she imagines him on her bed every
night
jackie who feels uncomfortable starts
talking to the shop's owner but she too
asks him to marry her daughter back at
home jackie writes poetry which is
uncommon for his gender while his
brother julian makes love to a woman in
the other room julian is a prostitute
whose ambition is to leave the country
one day he has been told that people
from other countries are allowed to
dance sing and eat varieties of food in
contrast to their sticky paste moreover
he believes that jackie's father had a
treasure hidden somewhere which he will
soon find he asks his brother to help
him with the mission but jackie claims
he has enough reasons to stay in this
country the following day jackie and his
mother go to buy tickets for the grand
bubunary ball but come across protesters
outside the ticket counter it turns out
that the men wishing to become the big
dummy should pay 40 000 boobs which most
men cannot afford because they live in
poverty jackie's uncle and his family
come out after buying the bright red
ticket to the ball they make fun of his
mother for being poor and boast about
how vergio is going to marry the
coloness
jackie returns home and cries himself to
sleep later he brings the police to his
own house accusing his brother julian of
not returning his money he believes that
their father had left them a treasure
that julen has been hiding from them as
the police search through their house
they find no treasure but get their
hands on a foreign magazine that is
forbidden in the country to jackie's
surprise julian is arrested for
possession he apologizes to his mother
saying that it was not his intention but
it is too late now however his guilt
turns into happiness when the sheriff s
gives him a free ticket to the ball in
return for his reporting julen the very
next day he happily goes to the clothing
store again to get himself clothes for
the ball upon returning he sees an
ambulance bringing his mother to the
hospital jackie quickly rushes to his
mother's side only to find out that she
had slipped and broken her neck she says
her last goodbye to her son and passes
away after the incident jackie starts to
live with his uncle's family who hates
him and treats him like a servant they
make him prepare the paste for hours and
spit it out saying that it isn't mashed
enough
one day he hears them talk about julen
escaping from prison and assume he died
when his house was burnt down jackie
freezes in shock knowing that he has no
one left by his side now he is at the
shop complaining to a sales girl about
his problems the girl who is also
attracted to jackie offers him a ride to
the grand ball in return for sexual
favors however while they are at it they
are caught by jackie's uncle upon
inspection they find jackie's ticket to
the ball and decide to give it to
virgil's younger brother jackie cries in
vain seeing his only opportunity to a
good life being taken away then virgil
and his brother get ready in beautiful
veils to finally go to the ball jackie
reluctantly helps them get ready one day
before the ball all the contestants in
beautiful white veils arrive at the
place the event is televised nationwide
jackie is at home crying when he hears
someone telling him to run away he
believes that it is the sacred horse
speaking and manages to run away from
his aunt's home after running in the
rain for a while three women stop him
and ask him why he is out taking
advantage of the poor guy's situation
they assault him just then julen appears
out of nowhere and kills the women to
save his brother he claims that he
provided sexual favors to the guards and
freed himself from the prison he has
been living in the forest and growing
plants ever since julen then shows
jackie a turnip farm proving that the
paste isn't the only thing humans can
eat and that the general s has been
lying to everyone julian's plan is to
sell the turnips to get enough money to
buy passports and leave the country he
includes jackie in his plan and the two
change into women's clothes and wear
wigs to disguise themselves julian also
reveals that their father was a rebel
who wanted equal rights for men they
founded a secret movement for men's
rights called meninism but he was hanged
for his efforts the two then get on a
horse and make their way to the palace
to sell the turnips they meet a higher
officer who happens to know julen's
secret and asks for a sexual favor
jackie is sent outside so he wanders
around the palace and eventually ends up
at the ball several men wearing the same
veil are impatiently waiting for the
colonesse's arrival some minutes later
the colonness and generaless arrive at
the ball jackie is left speechless by
the colonists beauty as she scans
through the crowd of men her eyes land
on jackie who is still dressed like a
woman they make eye contact but jackie
looks away flustered then the men
surround the colonists trying to prove
they are submissive and hence eligible
to be the big dummy meanwhile jackie is
approached by his uncle and his younger
son they mistake him for a girl and ask
him to marry the younger son jackie
shoots them away and makes his way to
the colonness she seems to be interested
in him even though he is dressed in
women's clothing he introduces himself
as jacqueline and is invited to her
private chamber there jackie and the
colonists talk for a long time about
many different things she tells him that
she wants to be a writer rather than a
leader but her mother won't let her she
also explains that the ball is just a
front to earn money and that she is set
to marry a movie star she then gives him
carrots to eat saying that the paste is
only for poor people
as the two talk the colon s starts
getting closer to jackie initiating
sexual advances but they are disturbed
by the general s who wants the colonists
to come back to the ball
now the big dummy is about to be
announced when suddenly jackie's uncle
recognizes him in the crowd and attacks
him
jackie's wig is torn off and he
announces his love to the colonness as a
man but the general s sends her guards
after him a chase ensues in the palace
jackie eventually ends up in a secret
room with several pipes upon
investigation he finds out that the
paste they have been eating is recycled
human feces mixed with vitamins the
general s has been giving speeches about
the paste being a gift to the nation but
in reality she is feeding the poor their
own [ __ ] so that they won't eat away all
the food and vegetables after learning
this jackie presses a button on the
control panel that causes the feces to
go to the water pipes without being
filtered the whole country is now
supplied with disgusting feces mixed
with their water the colonness is on her
bed when she hears noises from under it
she finds jackie inside and asks him his
true motive he confesses his love to her
and the two spend the night together in
the morning she shows him a crowd of men
outside the palace because he revealed
the truth about the pace the entire
country believes jackie to be a hero
however the general s doesn't share this
view so when he and the colonists are in
bed the guards arrest him and throw him
in jail the general s comes to visit him
in the prison and offers him a deal life
and marriage to her daughter in exchange
for his cooperation in preventing
rebellion
jackie accepts the offer but she tries
to cut off his tongue stating that he
has seen too much but before she can
harm him the colonist strangles her to
death
following that the new lovers reunite
and kiss together the two open the
borders of babuna and establish
democracy in the country jackie opens
schools for boys and travels the world
they also introduce emancipation and
restore the country's agriculture so
that people are provided with green
foods not feces in the last scene when
colin s and jackie are about to
officially marry they announce that
babunia wants no more secrets from its
people and strip naked in front of the
crowd revealing that colin s is actually
a man and that they in fact just entered
a gay marriage it turns out that the
general s had no daughters despite years
of trying so she wanted her last child
to become the state leader despite being
male the film ends with a woman from the
crowd yelling blasphemy at the two
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching